foreign
[Music]
Smith has worked in the harshest
conditions imaginable tracking the most
elusive cats on the planet
but now he has a new mission that will
bring us closer to the action than ever
before
thank you
all my life I've dreamed of being in the
middle of wild lions and they're killed
just to see what these guys are truly
capable of
this could be my big chance
if it stays in one piece
over the next hour I'll break down each
stage of Alliance kill so I can prepare
for the ultimate test locking myself
inside a specially engineered four by
seven foot clear acrylic box
inches from Wild Lions
we'll find out exactly what makes the
African Lion reign supreme
from the initial stocking strategy to
their high-speed Pursuit
and they're astounding leap
they're powerful takedowns and finally
the feast
test in the Box
welcome to the nambiti game reserve
in the heart of zulu Land South Africa
here 22 000 Acres of rugged terrain are
a Battleground for over 40 species of
game
[Music]
but within the constant fight for
survival
there is one Predator that has evolved
and fine-tuned its hunting ability to
become one of the most feared Warriors
in the land
the African Lion
[Music]
[Music]
's here on this Reserve I've been
tracking three of them all morning their
tracks are right here that big truck
right there that's big and Dotty he's
the dominant male and he's just over the
edge right here
just down the hill from him or his two
younger brothers blonding and mohawk
these three are known as the name Beatty
Brothers
you can hear him right there that's big
and donut and he's calling there's a new
female in the area and I got a hunch
that's who he's trying to find
it's clear that right now big and Dot is
the dominant male but Mohawk has a sized
him up you can see he's gonna be a big
cat and really soon he's gonna challenge
to be the dominant male here as well
lions are unique amongst all big cats
because they form Dynamic social groups
the most well-known form is the pride
usually consisting of multiple females
they're Cubs and an alpha male while the
females of the pride usually do most of
the hunting the male's role is that of
protector and patriarch to maintain his
status the alpha male must continuously
assert his dominance over any Challenger
the Exiles maturing males from the pride
and those Lions will sometimes band
together to form what is called a
coalition together they can become one
of the most fearsome forces in the
African bush
[Music]
the nambiti brothers are exactly that
they watch each other's backs and work
as a team to survive
now their long-standing bond will be put
to the test with a new female in the
area competition for mating rights will
be fierce
but until that day comes our brothers
will continue to hunt together
and as night falls
[Music]
their hunger grows
[Music]
Lions can make kills during the day but
they're way more active at night
[Music]
they take advantage of the cooler
temperatures and the cover of Darkness
to stop their friend
tonight we'll track the MPD brothers
from the sky cutting through the
darkness to give you an extraordinary
view of their attack strategy
this is the first stage of a lion's kill
the stalk
to track these guys nocturnal Behavior
we'll deploy this
a drone equipped with military grade
clear thermal imaging
not only will we have our eye in the sky
but we'll also have clear thermal
imaging on the ground and hopefully
we'll be able to capture some of their
hunting strategies
the brothers are in the area so we're
going to track them down and sea of the
Hunt is on
with our bird in the air it's like we're
switching on a light revealing the
Battleground that exists in the dead of
night
while we rely on cutting-edge technology
for our night vision the Lions rely on
their sophisticated adaptations a strip
of white fur underneath the eye helps
reflect extra Moonlight into the lens
there's also a mirror-like membrane at
the back of each eye that reflects light
into a high concentration of Rod cells
in their retina
this means the light coming into their
eyes is magnified when exposed to the
retina allowing them to see in the dark
giving the Coalition a real Edge over
their prey hey there there I got them
the two younger brothers
[Music]
they're heading right up this hill what
looks like a herd of wildebeest I think
Lions use highly developed teamwork when
they hunt spreading out each lion takes
a position for a strategic attack
Blondie takes The High Ground while
Mohawk closes in on the opposite side of
the herd team leader big and dada will
lead the charge down the middle with the
two brothers flanking it appears their
plan is to scatter the herd allowing
them to pinpoint an individual
[Music]
Springs into action he runs straight at
the center of the herd
the plan appears to be working as the
three wildebeest break away from the
crew
but their success is not long-lived the
prey manages to regroup and outrun the
brothers
foreign
the sun's coming up in about an hour but
these guys are definitely in hunting
mode so we're gonna see if we can keep
up with them and see what they get into
[Music]
the Sun in the sky means they've lost
the advantage of Darkness we've been
tracking the Lions all morning we just
saw them come across right here
lions
the brothers find a new Target
hippos
[Music]
check them out
they're flanking out they're gonna make
it go on the hippos right here they're
gonna make it go at him
they use the same attack strategy we saw
last night
but this time the alpha male big and
Dada flanks the herd while Mohawk takes
the center position
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
gets into the box for the ultimate test
[Music]
we're in the heart of South Africa
tracking the nambiti brothers a
coalition of three male lions
and along the way
breaking down each stage of a lion's
Gill
to prepare for the ultimate test
the Box
big cat tracker Boone Smith will be
inches away from Wild Lions breaking
down their social dynamics the only
thing I'm wondering
is well this box hold big and Dot and
his brothers show up
[Music]
right now we followed them to a watering
hole
they've crossed paths with an animal
responsible for the most human
fatalities in Africa hippos
Mohawk launches the attack from the
center big and daughter in bloody who
flank from the outside
they leave no Escape
those Lions locked under those hippos it
was like flipping a switch the burst of
speed the acceleration it was
vast how quick they moved this
high-speed Pursuit is the second stage
of a lion's kill
[Music]
hey Greg let's step right here this
place is perfect
I'm heading off the reserve to see
exactly what I'll be up against when I
enter the Box
in this controlled environment we'll
reveal one of the abilities that truly
make lions king of their domain
speed
what we've got here is a high speed
winch like the ones used to tow
wakeboarders
winch will pull a piece of piece of bait
through a clearing and the lions will
chase it down
I'll measure the line's speed with this
radar gun and we'll use slow motion
photography to analyze the mechanics of
the Lion's run all from the safety of
this blind
since both males and females might show
up at the Box we're testing the speed of
a four-year-old male and a two-year-old
lioness
okay lines up that's a big female
31 miles an hour that cat is flying boom
one big Power lunge and all of a sudden
she was at full stride
at the start of a lion's run the goal is
to achieve maximum acceleration
the Lioness coils her body into position
like a sprinter on a starting block
then she uses her hind legs together to
Spring Forward achieving top speed in a
few short bursts
the acceleration is just ridiculous how
fast they're from zero to 31.
once she's up to speed the Lioness
begins her gallop
there is a circular pattern to her foot
bones
the right Four Paw is followed by the
left
then the left heinpaw is followed by the
right
this is known as a rotary gallop and
it's a powerful method for rocketing
forward
and chasing down prey
it's the same type of gallop used by the
Lion's distant cousins the cheetah the
fastest land animal in the world
she's at top speed in about five yards
so the power and the acceleration is
what's really amazing on this now let's
compare the lionesses run with our adult
male
a line this size is what I'll be facing
inside the box if big and Dada or one of
his brothers shows up he's got to be
close to 500 pounds uh here we go
[Music]
[Music]
that was awesome big guys are so much
heavier so much more muscle but yeah 29
miles an hour
in the wild the Lion's top speed has
been clocked at over 45 miles per hour
that's not as fast as a cheetah but it
is faster than a Kentucky Derby
Thoroughbred
it's obvious that no human can outrun a
lion but after seeing that acceleration
in action it's clear that even the
fastest prey doesn't stand a chance if
taken by surprise
[Music]
back on the reserve the nambiti brothers
continue their search for sukhazi a
lioness that is new to the area and
ready to raise her own lion cubs
[Music]
while the brothers have spent most of
their adult lives together their Primal
instincts compel them to breed and start
their own Prides
the oldest brother big and Dada leads
and protects his younger brothers Mohawk
and Blondie
[Music]
but sukazi's presence on the reserve
might finally break the nambiti brothers
Bond
[Music]
along with a local guide Boon track
sukazi and her sister
if he can find her he can anticipate
where the brothers will go next he sees
something yeah and find the ideal place
to set up the box
[Music]
no on the rocky section there they're
lying there right next to each other
Boone locates sukhazi and her sister
they're golden yellow coats blend them
into the Tall Grass the perfect
camouflage for stalking prey
right now sukazi's doing what few apex
predators do
taking on an animal more than three
times her size
one kick from a giraffe's powerful long
legs can crush a lion's skull
tsukasi's best chance for success is to
strike before the giraffe knows she's
there
now that the giraffe sees her sukhazi
has only two choices back down or risk a
death blow by attacking
coming up we'll see how high we can get
these lines to jump we break down the
third stage of the attack oh wow at the
end of the hour I'll be face to face
with wild Lions and the only thing
between us would be one inch of acrylic
[Applause]
[Music]
deep in the African bush of the nambiti
game reserve we prepare for the ultimate
test
big cat tracker Boone Smith will lock
himself inside a box just inches away
from Wild Lions
to see what he's really up
we're breaking down the stages of a
lion's kill
revealing the powers that make them the
ultimate predator
now we track a lioness named sukhazi as
she stalks a giraffe
this herd of adult giraffes outweighs
ukazi by thousands of pounds
she plays it safe and calls off the hunt
usually it takes many lions to bring
down an animal as big as a giraffe and
to do it they have to get airborne
this leaping ability is critical to
their dominance in the wild
how high a lion can jump and what other
threats Boone May encounter while in the
Box we head off the reserve again to
work with lions in a controlled
environment to get these Lions leaping
I'm going to climb up this tree and hang
a bait
for the first attempt the bait is set
seven feet above the ground
wow she's coming in hot
she's right under it
[Music]
as the Lioness reaches the height of her
jump in instinctively a retractable
claws extend
[Music]
in a hunt this would be the point of
contact
penetrating the thick hide of her prey
just before she delivers a devastating
bite
[Music]
that was at seven feet and Jehovah was
no problem whatsoever boom
when a lion jumps they generate
explosive force this is made possible by
fast twitch muscle fibers these fibers
contract very quickly giving them
powerful bursts of energy
[Music]
the seven foot jump was easy so we
raised the bait to nine feet at this
height sukhazi could have easily reached
the hindquarters of the giraffe she
encountered all right so here she comes
[Music]
thinking about it right here I wanted to
see if I get a little higher we Max this
out
foreign
[Music]
just barely missed it she was way up
over the bait on that mist that's enough
height to get on the back of any animal
she'd encounter in the wild as our test
lion reaches maximum height her paw
swipe clears the bait by 10 inches
making this her best jump nearly 10 feet
so she's trying to figure out what to do
oh wow
and that's Ingenuity there
this whole idea that Lions don't climb
trees
not the case whatsoever you know this is
a great example of of what happens in a
hunting scenario it wasn't working like
you wanted so she's adapted on the Fly
utilize something else here the tree and
still end it up with what you wanted the
chunk of meat so not only powerful
but super intelligent as well
these claw marks are amazing they're
like a quarter inch deep in here if it's
that easy for her to get up this tree
can't imagine how easy it's going to be
for these lines to get up on top of the
box
back on the reserve we're on the hunt
again
we've been tracking these two female
lionesses all morning and they just
crossed and disappeared here into the
tall grass
[Music]
oh she's killing something right now
[Music]
just gotta work hard
coming up
stage four of a lion's hunt the takedown
and kill bind
and later
Boone comes face to face with an ambiti
Brothers
we're in the heart of South Africa
tracking the nambiti brothers
a coalition of three male lions they are
following a lioness named sukasi
she's ready for Cubs and the competition
to claim her as a mate could disrupt the
brothers Alliance
right there I think I think I see one I
think I see one
oh she's killing something right now
she's gotta work hard
[Music]
I can see the Tusk that's a great big
board it's got away close to 200 pounds
and she is on him
believe how effortlessly she just picked
up that warthog by the throat and was
just walking around with it it makes you
wonder how strong these cats really are
the true power of the African Lion is
revealed during the fourth stage of the
kill the takedown
measuring the strength of a lion will
give us a better idea of whether or not
the Box will hold when Boone's inside
to find out we will attach bait to the
end of a heavy duty digital scale when a
lion enters and grabs the bait
we'll determine exactly how much he can
pull
all right he's out here he comes guys
give him a little fight back right here
and see if I can get him to really lean
on it
thank you
[Music]
watch out
watch out 1500 pounds right there on
just that
the secret behind the Lion's Incredible
strength is revealed in their muscle
anatomy compared to a human's a lion's
muscle fibers can be half the size
allowing them to pack in more per square
inch and not only can the density be
higher each fiber is 2.6 times more
powerful
if this lone male can pull 1500 pounds
what could the combined power of the
nambiti brothers do to
strength that these guys have with the
the muscle structure plus the the fiber
strength because it's just mind-boggling
[Music]
Lions use their Incredible strength to
take down prey that can be more than
three times their size but ultimately
the killing blow is delivered with a
bite
they use their powerful jaws to clamp
down on their praised throat crushing
the trachea and suffocating them to
death
[Music]
back on the reserve we're hot on the
trail of big and Donna
he's been following sukazi for hours and
it seems as though she's playing hard to
get
I got some right here going through the
grass right here off the right side hey
this is it this is the line this line we
got a line right here right here on our
three o'clock
Devin get a light on it
okazi and and he's acting cautious
[Music]
she spots big and daughter and heads in
his Direction
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but big and daughter isn't giving up
[Music]
so you guys are definitely getting up
and starting to go on the move right now
while big and daughter courts sukazi his
younger brothers Mohawk and Blondie
watch from afar
[Music]
sukazi accepts big and Dada by raising
her tail a sign of submission
but now Mohawk approaches
big and daughter will not stand for the
presence of a second male even if it's
his brother
the bond between these three dominant
Predators is about to be put to the test
they're locked up seriously they are
locked up
coming up
the power struggle between the brothers
intensifies oh as boom finally enters
the Box
we're in South Africa tracking the
nambiti brothers
a coalition of male lions that are
following a lioness named sukhazi last
night things got intense when all four
cats crossed paths holy cow
now
a New Day brings a new alliance
vegan daughter Remains by sukazi's side
for now he's left his younger brothers
Mohawk and Blondie to fend for
themselves but tonight the bond between
the brothers will be tested as we reveal
the final stage of a lion's kill the
feast
and for that I prepared something
special
a state-of-the-art clear acrylic cage
nine transparent panels are bolted
together with marine grade steel we
machined eight inch filming ports on
each side and my entry point a stainless
steel brick secured by four quick
release latches with this box I'll have
my own seat at the dinner table
put me inches away from the Lions while
they feed
I'll be able to see the most minute
facial expressions and literally feel an
infrasonic vocalizations between the
cats this test will put their social
dynamics under a microscope
I'm gonna bait the area to lure the
Lion's in and the main course a fresh
wildebeest carcass strapped to the top
of the box
oh
so we've just locked ourselves in the
Box we know that we've got at least two
lines very close to us
and now it's kind of the Moment of Truth
as the sun sets Boone and his cameraman
Devin wait for the Lions to arrive
I can do the lines Ward
[Applause]
I know they're close there's a good
chance they're gonna come I'm gonna
slide back here and position and hide
and
see what happens here
[Music]
foreign
looks like a female
wait wait you see that
she's not alone
big guy
if big and daughter is here with sukazi
his younger brothers can't be far behind
is coming away
in front of your right
you hear that
scratching
that club
scratching the glass on my side
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
situation with a fresh kill big and
daughter the alpha male would eat first
but with sukazi present something has
clearly changed
foreign
the brothers position themselves behind
the box their focus is not on the
carcass
they're more curious about what's inside
that was intense man
[Music]
foreign
still hunker down behind boom yeah
Alliance
all four cats surround the box at last
the hierarchy amongst the Coalition will
be revealed
[Music]
get ready it's gonna get wild
[Music]
because
she's coming back
with the lure bait gone and all the
lions around it's time to serve the main
course
in a feeding situation like this we'll
be able to see exactly how sukazi's
presence affects the social Dynamic
within the coalition
touching the Box
ES
watch this video right here
above my head
we have feeding
that it should be
his brother shut his whole head in there
big and daughter stays by sukkazi's side
not leaving her exposed to his brothers
that is unreal
awesome
[Music]
but will it stay in one piece
it's the dead of night on the nambiti
game reserve
and we're throwing a very unusual dinner
party
right now
our guests are getting rowdy
oh
we're getting crushed against the tree
here of Houston
we have a problem
so they're trying to take the kill and
move
and move it and when they pulled it the
cable hooked on the the middle brace on
the bottom I'm talking over 1200 pounds
and they're just spinning it
effortlessly
man
literally three feet
from line to floating on the cargo's
right here
oh man
vegan daughter takes position 10 feet
behind his brothers and sukhazi
normally the dominant male big and
daughter would be the first to eat
[Music]
but tonight his younger brother's
Blondie and Mohawk claimed the kill
my gosh
though he's pissed
[Music]
watching this ball
about to find out where the hierarchy
really stands
big and Dada must decide
assert his dominance over his brothers
or stay by sukazi side
[Music]
thank you
so the two brothers have laid claim to
the carcass
and
I came in and tried to feed
and he's been The Hobbit all night he's
been the dominant male he's random
feathers away from the female
but one thing and Donnie came in to try
and feed they teamed up
at the carcass
and now between the two of them there's
no competition they're not fighting
they're not competing they're both just
gorgeous fast as they can on this
carcass
big and Dada chooses not to fight his
focus is on the continuation of his
bloodline
for now he lets his brothers dine alone
all the tests we've done have led up to
this right here
feast the final stage of a lion's kill
where we truly see what makes the
African Lion unique in the world of big
cats
they rule the African plains for one
very simple reason
their social structures
in a pride or a coalition their unique
bonds give them an advantage from
Cooperative hunting to protecting each
other they have strength in numbers
this combined with their incredible
physical abilities
makes the African Lion
Supreme
thank you
foreign
[Music]